this is a historic day at 12:01 this
morning the city of Eagleton ceased to
exist and was reabsorbed back into
Pawnee things are exactly the way they
were back in 1817
except you know women and minorities can
vote we have indoor toilets and we no
longer burn widows for learning
arithmetic Councilwoman Knope is your
mergers are and in the binders that
she's provided you will find directions
to your department in Pawnee that most
closely matches your department in
Eagleton there are two Eagleton
departments Pawnee does not have the
Department of infinity pool design and
the Department of dressage which I am
told is a fancy horse riding thing it is
horse dancing madam okay take it easy
Alonso all you horse dancing people sit
in your saddles if you will the rest of
you welcome to your new departments
attention Eagleton is now under martial
law no who's ready to play 60 the NFL
has a campaign to try to get kids active
for 60 minutes per day and so we bust in
a hundred lucky little buggers from
Pawnee and they are gonna get a chance
to play with the Colts okay I guess you
would know pleasure to see you again mr.
luck we met briefly last year at our
friend's bachelor party oh yeah
right how are you I normally don't
answer that question but since I respect
your talent I will tell you I am fine hi
I'm April I stole your wallet guys are
weird
thank you sup girl keep walking
ninety-eight you didn't want to talk to
that guy he plays in the NFL he's a
linebacker skill positions only for
Donna mEagle
I got my cold bTW my cold scarf I got
the coats grill going
and the crowning glory cold slippies how
you gonna run a nose run Tommy doesn't
run that's your guys's job now uh let's
go fetch his football throw fellas I
love sports okay Ron enough snap let's
talk plans for Diane's baby chef dear
God
three main activities baby bingo baby
food tasting and my personal favorite
baby onesie decorating station I'm gonna
make mine look like an astronaut what
are you doing up there in space baby oh
so cute okay I have some gift ideas I
was looking at a very adorable stroller
we already have a stroller oh shoot
really never think of something else oh
my god whose baby is that that would be
mine guys get in here
ron is a baby Oh Ron cool baby thank you
Andrew everyone I'd like to introduce
you to my son John middle name redacted
Swanson John was born some time ago
weighing multiple pounds and several
ounces much like his father he is a fan
of silence please keep your voices down
how am I supposed to keep my voice down
when you had your baby baby why would
you need to know something like oh my
god I'm not even sent Diana gift she's
just walking around wondering why I
haven't sent her a gift yet should we do
something just let her tire or cell
phone if you need anything from us Ron
please just let us know actually there
is something could one of you please
stop by the pet store and pick up some
fish food for me
I found this typewriter next to the
courtyard dumpster and old Underwood 5
with original carriage return took her
home polished her up bought a brand new
ribbon off of electronic bait calm okay
somebody's got to do something I'm
getting a cluster headache oh he's
leaving let's go I'm gonna throw it away
no I'm not where's Billy done sir
what is he type in any way if you sons
of [ __ ] try to remove this typewriter
I'll kill you every word I know
rectangle America megaphone Monday
butthole gee whiz the Harvest Festival
was a real triumph
we had over 80,000 people in attendance
which surpassed our wildest expectations
I would like to specifically single out
Leslie Knope I speak for the mayor City
Council and all upon me when I say we
can't wait to see what the heck you're
gonna do next step on up here les are
you okay
that was the second most Awkward way a
man has ever grabbed my breasts as well
as a 7% surcharge on all non-local
business-related development together we
will build a better Pawnee so what we're
looking for here are your overall
impressions of this candidate what do
you like about her what don't you like
about her her ideas her voice her
clothes probably well my campaign is a
little momentum so we're trying to
capitalize on that by doing a focus
group some things are very helpful other
things are not so helpful all the things
make me feel a lot of feelings about
myself she's kind of sure don't you
think aggressively short almost it's
like she's throwing it in my face
insightful you sir said you would not
vote for her correct
yeah yes she seems a little uptight she
doesn't seem a the kind of person you
could go bowling with you know what
that's ridiculous I am excellent at
bowling ask Ron Leslie I know it's tough
to hear these things but this trying to
get obsessed over one comment I'm
totally right I'm not obsessing okay
what are you doing he's reminding myself
to tell Ron to tell you how good I am at
bowling all right I actually thought
that she was smart and I'd vote for her
there you go although I once knew and
Leslie and she was just awful so now I
hate all Leslie's did she consider
changing your name well it's a pleasure
to be here ladies I didn't think anybody
really cared about my time on the City
Council oh we do I mean you were such an
inspiration still going strong at 82
well it's not a handkerchief it's a
receipt Paula hork was pawnees first
female city councilor 40 years ago and
she was a huge inspiration to me women
have come a long way in Pawnee but we
still have quite a ways to go I mean
technically I'm not allowed to reserve
this conference room without my husband
or Father's signature government was a
real boys club back in the 70s they
smoked their cigars they snapped my bra
or mirrors on their shoes to look up my
skirt well I'm happy to report that it
is now a pervert free people's club well
except for councilman Dex Hart who's a
self-described
yeah and didn't Milton try to kiss you
well yeah things aren't perfect all the
other councilmen used to keep a calendar
my menstrual cycle are you kidding me
that is horrible they don't do that to
me do they do that to me
I once tried to start a commission to
try to get more jobs for women in city
government and they dismissed me saying
that it was because it was just my time
of the month admittedly they were right
because of their calendar man pigs all
of them you know what I'm gonna get that
Commission going because this inequality
has gone on long enough you know what I
think men are better than women she's
kidding no I'm not they provide for us
and we must obey them because they are
our masters April stop it Leslie you'll
never land a bow with that domineering
tone we must always walk behind the mesh
Washington DC take a deep breath Andy I
mean you can practically smell the bills
becoming laws you can taste the sweet
sugar of bureaucracy at work that
building looks like a boob yeah well
it's not oh yeah I know it's the White
House yeah it's the Capitol my amazing
lover Ben Wyatt is here working on a
congressional campaign and he took April
with him as his intern I'm here to visit
but I'm also here to work because I have
a very important meeting where I am
going to try to get federal funding so
we can clean up the Pawnee River it's a
bit of a fixer-upper
romantic reunions government meetings
self-guided museum tours I mean am i
living the dream I don't know did I also
just walk past a food truck and buy
myself a waffle sundae yes
now take out your guidebook oh I didn't
bring a gun mom I brought you one you
did yeah thank you
now throw it away does Leslie Knope is
your guy but I didn't
and I mean literally some notes in it
okay grab his work and let's hit the
National Mall there's the mall that's
awesome I need to get some flip-flops
hey getting ready for your nightly Skype
date with Andy in London you look lovely
I'm going to murder you a thousand times
[Music]
God what are you doing here missed you
so bad honey I bought myself a ticket
home
you're never gonna need that computer
again cuz I'm home for like 19 hours
this is so sweet
just like the old days take a hike Jerri
it's weird Oh
you